musique étrangère
ouais
tu dois forcer ça à sortir qu'est-ce que
tu fais
tu es un génie je sais ce que j'ai dit
oh tu savais ce qui allait arriver à
mon frère quand tu l'as coincé avec cette
chose destructrice du monde
qu'on appelle le  Scarabée,
je ne savais pas qu'il s'activerait, il
doit choisir, tu
sais comment faire pour qu'il me désélectionne, acquis
qui a dit que la distance
non
étrangère,
le monde est un endroit à protéger, j'ai
un Arsenal à ma disposition n'importe quoi s'il te
plaît ouais
c'est plus comme ça
bonjour tu ressens pour ta famille qui te rend
faible tu as tort ma famille c'est ça qui
me rend fort
oh j'ai oublié à quel point ça a l'air mauvais Cible
la famille
désolé ma maman
tu es notre super-héros allez
tu es le Blue Beetle si je pouvais utiliser
ça  Arsenal en ce moment Dieu tu
n'as jamais demandé oh ouais
je me conseille de reculer
maintenant